[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in sallys welt
heute starte ich mit meinem fertigen
gericht denn ich muss euch zeigen es
gibt heute pablo war pablo ist einfach
ein ganz ganz tolles bisher aus einer bp
schicht das ist das hier unten im ofen
getrocknet gebacken wie auch immer man
es nennen mag dann mit creme das so und
ich hab das ganze serviert oder
fertiggestellt mit granatapfel kennen
ich muss sagen das ist ein bisher was
man hervorragend vorbereiten kann es ist
ein des servers folgen her macht und es
ist das her was einfach megamäßig gut
schmeckt ihr könnt das ganze sogar vegan
zu bereiten tbc master mache ich zwei
aus eiweiß und zucker aber ihr können
statt eiweiß zum beispiel auch aqaba
nehmen das ist dass gibson war es
erkennt wenn ihr kichererbsen aus der
dose verwendet und dann könnt ihr dieses
gericht wirklich auch hervorragend vegan
zu bereiten einfach die milchprodukte
dann auch austauschen durch veganer
alternativen und dann habt ihr das eher
was für jeden geeignet ist zuerst werde
ich jetzt mal die baiser masse
herstellen und sage ich dafür die
zutaten dafür nämlich 61 eine prise salz
300 gramm zucker und dann noch etwas
vanille extrakt und stärke hier ist
einfach wichtig dass ihr das eiweiß gut
vom eigelb trend dass da einfach keine
fettrückstände mit dabei sind saubere
fettfrei schüssel und dann kommt es hier
rein ihr könnt es auch mit dem
handrührgerät machen aber ihr müsst bei
sondern pablo war wirklich lange röhren
salz kommt noch dazu und jetzt auch der
zucker direkt am anfang mit rein
schubst alles rein und dann wird es
jetzt schön aufgeschlagen und steif
geschlagen bis der zucker sich gelöst
hat das kann halt schon mal 15 bis 20
minuten dauern aber das ist richtig
[Musik]
so sieht sie perfekt aus ich muss auch
sagen die war bei mir schon nach zehn
minuten etwas richtig gut und zwar macht
ihr jetzt den finger test
und treibt die pc masse zwischen ihren
fingern und wenn ihr keine
zuckerkristalle mehr spürt dann ist die
masse perfekt wenn ihr noch
zuckerkristalle spürt dann müsste sie
noch länger hören aber das muss ein
guter test und da kommt jetzt die stärke
dazu
und etwas von den exakt ich habe jetzt
auch den ofen schon vorgeheizt auf 190
grad heißluft und falls ihr keine
heißluft habt könnt ihr auch gerne ober
unterhitze verwenden dann nehmen wir
einfach 20 grad mehr das ganze schön
vorheizen heißluft oder umluft ist
einfach ein bisschen besser weil da die
pc machst du schön trocknen kann bei
ober unterhitze klappt aber auch ihr
könnt dann einfach nur bei ein oder zwei
mal so die backofentür öffnen damit
einfach die feuchtigkeit entweichen kann
und dann jetzt einfach vorsichtig
unterheben
[Musik]
weil ich jetzt ein lochblech und eine
dauer back folie und wer das ganze jetzt
als dringen praktisch auftragen ihr
könnt euch jetzt ein bisschen
hilfslinien machen und zwar hier ihr
könnt euch zum beispiel einen tortenring
nehmen und denen sie ein bisschen in
stärke tauchen
dann habe ich eine schöne linie und kann
dass sie gut auf tragen jetzt kommt es
hier gleichmäßig als kranz hin ich bin
bis jetzt auch keinen kranz machen das
ganze einfach und machen aber ich finde
so ein schöner kann es ist schon schön
und um es gleichmäßig aufzutragen hole
ich den ice portionierer dann setze ich
mir erstmal zügeln drauf
rings herum
[Musik]
jetzt habt ihr so eure grundform und
nimmt am besten eine palette messer oder
einen löffel und formt daraus jetzt
einen schönen krankes und zwar erst mal
relativ glatt streichen
dem ist er jetzt hier darauf achten dass
die bbc machte im ofen noch ein bisschen
auf geht also jetzt nicht zu groß machen
den kreis ich hatte den jetzt 20 cm groß
den ring und jetzt könnt ihr hier so ein
bisschen von außen nach innen
das ganze schön formen
[Musik]
und jetzt praktisch die schöne farbe
und dafür sehe ich selbst von unten nach
oben
[Musik]
und jetzt kommt in den vorgeheizten
backofen wie gesagt bei heißluft 190
grad sobald die freien stelle schalte
ich den backofen aber runter auf 90 grad
heißluft denn ich brauche am anfang
dieser heiße luft damit das ganze
einfach so ein bisschen eine kruste
bekommt und später darf den backofen
einfach nur noch austrocknen außen
bleibt die pullover und das der die
tasten pavlova ich weiß es nicht genau
schön knusprig und innen so richtig
marshmallow mäßig weicht das ganze
braucht so etwa eine stunde 20 im ofen
und dann einfach den ofen ausschalten im
backofen auskühlen lassen und später
dann fertig garen
[Musik]
meine partei war habe ich im backofen
abkühlen lassen jetzt ist sie perfekt
ihr könnt ihr gerne auch einen tag
vorher schon zu bereiten dann einfach in
der küche stehen lassen oder im ofen
ebenen auskühlen lassen und dann ist sie
einfach schon bereit das was jetzt
obendrauf kommt ist praktisches topping
und ich werde das jetzt machen mit einer
leckeren quark sahne creme die wir doch
gar nicht gesucht weil er wirklich die
baiser masse einfach dieses süße
mitbringt und dann kommt hier durch so
ein bisschen frische mit rein ich werde
das ganze auch gleich mit granatapfel
kern und belegen ihr könnt da aber gerne
jedes obst drauflegen was ihr möchtet
und wirklich die parole war aus
deckungen wie wollt ihr könnt auch
schokoladig gestalten zitronig gestalten
es schmeckt einfach alles in verbindung
mit baiser und sahne creme wollte ich
noch dazu sagen und am besten dann erst
anrichten so eine stunde 23 vor verzehr
ansonsten wird sie einfach sehr weich
schmeckt zwar auch noch gut aber ich
würde jetzt nicht am tag vorher machen
und dann servieren dass es dann einfach
zu weich also schmeckt schon besser ich
sage ich mal eben die zutaten dafür
nämlich 250 gramm quark 300 gramm sahne
beides natürlich kalt etwas vanille
extrakt und für die dekoration grand
prix gerne etwas rosmarin und süßen
schnee es geht jetzt auch recht schnell
aber die sahne mit wannen extrakt kurz
aufschlagen
[Musik]
ok
wenn die sahne steif geschlagen ist gebt
ihr den quark dazu
und rührt den auch noch kurz ein und
dann ist die sauerei hier zu ende
und dann wird nicht mehr über mich
gelacht hier hinten also kostet so und
verrührt
nämlich hier die partnerwahl und selbst
schon mal auf ne servierplatten
sagen die servierplatten das sind die
wir jetzt gerade ganz neu haben aber das
ist eine kleinere denn die die wir
letztendlich macht damit die spiele
größer
daher bauen schönen rand teppich zum
grab da deswegen jetzt die jetzt von der
größe her passt dass jetzt auch ganz gut
und jetzt kommt die creme da drauf und
da könnt ihr euch jetzt wirklich deko
mäßig einfach austoben ich werde das
jetzt hier so machen dass ich die hier
oben tatsächlich so ein bisschen
einbreche
da kommt jetzt die creme rein
[Musik]
ich lebe jetzt schon und dann kommen da
die granata prekäre drauf die haben
jetzt bereits entkernt ihr könnt mal
gerne schauen ich habe nämlich neulich
einen short hochgeladen in dem ich zeige
wie man einen granatapfel entkernen kann
drei varianten dazu die erste ist man
spaltet sie gut auf die zweite ist man
hämmert alles raus die erste nase ein
bisschen spritzig muss ich dazu sagen
die dritte variante ist unter wasser da
könnt euch einfach aus was ihr machen
wollte jetzt klingt diese granatapfel
kerne die passen hallo perfekt mit ihrer
säure diese fruchtigkeit es passt
einfach perfekt in dieses gesamtkonzept
da kommt es hier ein bissle rosmarin
drumrum bisschen süßen schnee drauf und
dann habt ihr so ein schönes leckeres
gericht von leckerer nachtisch
vielleicht erwischt der noch so ein
bisschen kann hat auch für saft und dann
könnt ihr den so runter tropfen lassen
und das macht sie perfekt
rosmarin
aus dem garten den packe ich halt dazu
weil ein bisserl was grün ist schon so
nicht fehlen würde
geschmacklich wird minister ganz gut
passen aber ich finde dass man in der
sie halt so winterlich aus wieso
tannenzapfen tannennadeln und
deswegen packe ich denen es dazu
[Musik]
es sieht einfach so schön aus und ich
bin so glücklich über dieses konzept ich
liebe pullover ich liebe es einfach ich
mache dir die küche sauber das ganze
darf jetzt im kühlschrank ein bisschen
durchziehen haben jetzt ist hinweis wird
die wir sehen was da oben drauf und da
könnten wir sie probieren
da läuft euch doch auch schon das wasser
im mund zusammen oder
[Musik]
okay jetzt kann die parole war probiert
werden
vom girls
[Applaus]
ok kennt ihr paulo wo habt ihr das schon
mal gegessen noch nie
das ist mit gps und creme
die einen macht übrigens
die einzige macht übrigens die
wunderschönen bilder der pablo
hier warte ich schneide noch zu viel
dass man gleich das bild noch ja
und das besondere ist die chancen halt
so knusprig und innen so reich wie
der murat halt außen harter kern im
inneren aber weich
kraft allemal
aber ich muss ganz kurz gekommen ich
musste die konsistenz zeigen hier sieht
man es nämlich volk hier außen so
richtig knusprig und innen so dass die b
c
ist nicht so extrem süß
welche nur zucker im bch und der creme
kein zucker ja natürlich und die
granatapfel kerne die sind einfach so so
säuerlich und dann schreibt einfach gut
sehr lecker
[Musik]
und es sieht doch aus als hättest du am
meisten die dort machen aber hier ganz
ehrlich da braucht man nicht mal
werkzeug dafür richtig ist das ist
einfach das doch wahnsinn so lecker und
so gut ist darunter hinunter schön
ach schön ich freue mich dass es
schmeckt hier und ich könnte mir halt
auch gut vorstellen da passt wie gesagt
auch passt noch andere früchte drauf
heidelberg himbeeren was auch immer ihr
grad da hat und was auch immer ihr gerne
mögt und probiert gerne aus wirklich ist
eine ganz ganz große empfehlung von uns
oder ich glaubte schmeckte und falls
jetzt doch schokolade schmeckt dann
reibt da noch schokolade drauf oder
rasten die drüber perfekt also das
rezept findet er in meiner app und auch
verließ - blog.de viel spaß beim
nachmachen wir werden jetzt noch kurz
fotos schießen und dann kanns online für
euch
[Musik]